The Joe Rogan experience.
So in college now you're athletic careers in order,
you're,
you're getting your schoolwork in.
What was it that made you even consider being an MMA fighter?
Ben Ashker yet funky ban on Cuban and I didn't even consider he tricked her
cause I check you me all through,
cause I had teammates at data MMA,
they all wrestled when I was over.
They all of amateur MMA fights.
Of course you should try it like your movement.
So you're so light on your feet and fast as your weight.
You can kill it bounced.
I got a metal plate in my leg,
bro.
I had tore my shoulder and I got some marriage.
I wouldn't be good.
I'd be laid up too much like I didn't like what'd you think?
This isn't,
this denied,
denied.
Denied.
My senior year,
fifth year senior Ben comes up,
you start working with me and Ben was like one of my main wrestling partners and
Kinda like you say with Lemon Chieko like you got somebody you go to punch and
he's not there because the same way on wrestling.
And I used to try to pick his brain and how do you do this?
Like I'd be dead right on a AA,
pick you up in the air.
I go to take you down and I land on my face and you're nowhere to be found.
You on my back or how does that happen?
That's why they call me the fuck man.
I'm the king.
Get a fuck the same hair.
Come in,
practice standards,
kick it off,
put his shoes on.
He just looked like a floppy guy.
Like,
Hey,
this guy is crazy thing about him.
He doesn't look physically in person going like this is,
this has been like this.
No,
I'm about to blow through this.
Do Hidden with Aa.
Gone every time.
High Crotch gone.
I took him down,
I think one time my college career clean take down and then it's just like what
the,
and after college I was like,
I want to do the Olympics Bro.
And you've been there.
I don't know any freestyle rules.
Oh,
we can work together,
whatever.
Him and my coach both for us.
So at that Olympic level working together.
And then one day sent me,
I was like,
oh,
I'm not making it here today,
but meet me here at this address and we will work,
blah blah,
blah.
Bring a year.
I get up there and Rufus sport,
but it's outside of a bank.
It's still like,
is there any for bank downstairs?
Yeah,
because I'm looking like we don't fuck is,
where am I going?
I texted like,
oh,
go to the side.
It's downstairs.
You're going shit,
sign roof for sport,
this and this,
and I walk downstairs like,
what is,
he must have mats in your song and I go in there and you got UFC,
they're doing a Anthony Pettis doing a jump off kick and making some photo for
the magazine or whatever and you got like Pascal crew s and Sergio Perez.
You got Ben Astron.
It was a few other Eric Koch,
other UFC guys and I'm looking like,
what is going on?
I always got hidden pass and when my practice and being around at the k,
oh hey cool,
I'm glad you could make this,
this and this.
Let's say no wrestling gym.
What is this?
He's like,
Oh yeah,
well I want to talk to you about that.
We're going to a new sport.
What?
Yes,
like,
I mean,
I know,
I heard you say you didn't want to fight whatever,
bro.
I think you could be good.
I just want you to try.
If you don't,
if you don't like it after you try it,
we'll go back to wrestling,
blah blah blah,
this and this.
I'm like,
hi.
And I go to the front desk and the lady I met at the front desk,
they introduced me.
It was my wife now didn't know that genesis in mind.
That's like what this,
so I get the gear that gave me some gloves and whatever and I was like,
you know,
I really don't want to do like the training I saw on the side and watch.
I hit the bag a little bit.
I'm just watching and at the time this is where my mind already set.
You got an opportunity,
you got to try it.
But I didn't try the day.
I remember driving home an hour and a half dry.
Hold your,
I've met myself like you pitch talking about that like you a bitch court,
you didn't do that.
You had opportunity.
I even take it.
You a bitch.
I can't believe you didn't do that.
So I get home until being like,
I'm sorry I didn't try but I like to do it again like well it's good cause
tomorrow morning 9:00 AM we up there.
I get up early seven 35 and motorcycle up shoot all the way up to Milwaukee.
I get their roof and do group element.
Oh Cory,
nice to meet you.
I heard about she has a snitch.
Like I can't,
yes,
I didn't do it but I want to try it today.
I just was like,
well that's good.
I'm glad you came.
Like why is that like stay sparring day?
Like I had to borrow testing.
I did amateur boxing.
They call him.
I broke my leg.
I did like boxing in the gym for Rehab.
Come out.
Brother-In-Law was oppression of box at the time and I had two amateur fights
and uh,
so I had that and I came on my gloves,
everything but over ready,
title gloves falling apart and like all I got is my gloves,
my show.
It's like,
Oh man,
we've got gear would get you stuff.
Hey gear and Shin pads,
this is this.
They gave me two obviously combat corner Shin pads,
almost like a youth and was like extra loss on one coach,
my knee and one covered like half machine.
Like there's old raggedy head gear.
You got a mouthpiece like yeah man,
it's all you need.
So we're going to spa.
So my first time I go with being so being,
you know,
taking it easy on me.
Boom,
boom.
He shoot on me.
I defended in MMA is different.
I can sprawl out hard.
I well there you go.
I'm going to put you with somebody else.
Of course,
Anthony Pettis,
he's too small like,
well you need to go and feel like they get kicked.
What bow?
I just kept kicking my leg.
Not Great.
Like what are you do?
Like I'm arrest as I take them down.
That's when I lie.
You do big family,
you're going to hurt him and he put me with a heavyweight.
So now we'll just take everything you did.
Use punched him being and you took him down and took nine.
Anthony do everything.
We've just got your size and I fucking just hit her with a bunch of Jab Crosses,
blasts devil on a punch.
It's like just got dino ground but there's hidden like dog and it stand up and
do it again.
I did get as kept doing and doing it,
doing it and when I was over here like hey,
there you go.
Your first sponsor is not the way he said.
I hate to tell.
The court heard you kept saying you're not a fighter but you aren't MMA fighter
and I can tell you right now,
but working with a lot of guys,
you could be in the UFC and three fights.
Yeah,
right.
Whatever.
I'm feeling like I'm dead serious in three fights.
So what you got and your mentality from what I seen in wrestling,
if you put into this,
you can read in the UFC in three fights,
whatever,
but I liked that.
I like to train it and I kept coming back and I never received Jesus.
This was 2012 right after college.
That's not that long ago,
man.
Oh my [inaudible] to 2013 top level MMA fighter in one of the most talent rich
divisions in the light heavyweight division.
And you only been doing it for seven years.
I was in the UFC was seven months after my first fight,
seven months and I was at a top 10 within a year.
That's the thing.
So I'm learning.
I didn't have amateur career.
I had three fights on ultimate fighter one that top 10 year of all MMA training.
That's it.
That's what people keep talking this shit about.
I'm like,
they don't understand.
I ain't did this.
Like most of these guys,
I look at pictures of guys I've been training with.
I got guys at the gym now that's still amateurs.
They pose a throwback Thursday,
my senior year in college.
I have a throwback picture.
It'd be me in college in 2007 it'd be them on like the third or fourth MMA
fight.
It's like,
and these guys are still amateur and how old are you now?
I'm 29 dude,
you're still not even really in your prime.
You know I was like 31 32 back.
I said I'm coming.
I'm learning now.
You are learning now but that's crazy that you were in a top 10 a year in the
MMA training.
They'll just,
cause we always cite Francis in Ghana.
The Francis in Ghana is one of the craziest stories ever.
The guy goes from no MMA training at all to five years later fighting for the
title you know at like him,
but he's,
what you did is as impressive the fact that you hit top 10 with a year of MMA
training.
That's bananas,
man.
Even in the tough house,
I remember guys like you hear him in a kitchen with all talking about,
oh what's your background in business?
I went on a tough with four or five months experience,
had my three fights back to back to bed and I remember my coach was pushing it.
That third fight we got hit to certify.
Why are you pushing so hard?
And then when it was over and I was like,
oh hi.
That's why we had to get that last fight.
Ultimate fighter trials.
The next Tuesday in Indiana,
you're going the fuck outta here.
I gotta work.
This is,
I'm going over there and they called me Monday night like,
Yo,
you're doing like I'm at work.
I work night shift.
I don't get off til one.
And when he'd get off me,
me and my house like what are we going on in Indiana?
Like I'm not,
I'm going get to USC.
How I'm gonna do it.
I'm going to go to the hallway.
All right.
I see at my house,
hung up the phone,
I get off,
I'll go.
And I was like,
Bro,
what the fuck you talkin about?
He jumped into driving.
She's like getting like,
what are you talking about?
So you are saying you want,
if you get in,
you want to go the hard way.
Getting earned from doing the ultimate fight.
Yeah.
I wanted to like get enough fights and then somebody see me and be like,
oh here's you take a short notice fight or whatever.
That was a fantastic opportunity for exposure and exactly in my mind I just
started three,
four months.
I'm thinking like I'm just beating up cans.
I don't think I'm ready yet.
But they say like,
oh,
we see you man.
Like you,
you have the opportunity to beat these guys.
Like you'd beaten this guy and he's been training forever.
He's been pro has been dilatory.
Dustin Jacoby was my first barn partner when I went to Illinois.
He had been in the UFC Laurie now.
Yeah.
And that was one of my first and I was taking him down and ground and pound but
striking.
I didn't have it,
but it's usually take downs,
man,
you've taken everybody now you're doing good.
Use that.
And when I left,
when I went there and whatever,
my coach is like,
just go do what you do.
I have no doubt they're going to pick you.
But the reason they picked me wasn't the same.
You know,
they picked me thinking it was going to be easy fight for whoever,
but it's backfired on me because my work ethic,
they didn't know me.
You know I was cracking jokes like I can be anybody you haven't,
it is laughing.
I'm going,
they laughing at my jokes,
come to find out,
they told me at the end,
one guy told me like,
you know when we picture we didn't think you could win.
I go after somebody like we picked you because we thought she was going to lose
it,
Kelly and this and get him an easy fight in and now look,
it kind of backfired.
And it was like,
cause they didn't know who I was.
They didn't know her as a person.
And I name Drop Matt Hughes and I think that was the only reason why I got
there.
Like I trained with Matt Hughes here and there,
Blah Blah.
You Know Maddie?
Aw Man,
he's our guy.
Oh,
can you make it to Vegas next week?
I think I can make it yesterday.
If he would have told me like go pack your bags,
you're going,
wow,
that was it.
But you,
the thing is,
even though
you were a year in,
you are so many years into wrestling and I think to this day that wrestling is
the most important skill in MMA because you get to dictate where the fight takes
place.
The superior wrestler gets a dis,
every fight starts standing up and you have to know how to strike.
But a superior wrestler guests to dictate where the fights take place.
And you see that with guys like Khabib,
he see that with so many superior grapplers when they get ahold of a guy,
it's their dominance is one of the most important aspects of fighting.
So you did have all that
[inaudible] that's,
I had the strike,
the basic striking wrestling.
Like I said,
when I came to meet Mark Henry and Ricardo Meda like bass,
it took me until two years into your chat with him in two years.
I was a year and like three months.
And I guess that's why I didn't have it.
And mark tell people all the time like when you hear him say it,
I,
I'm telling people all the time,
you guys want to see like,
oh I'm working with having core high court is a purifier of what I,
what I'm coaching because he came here with nothing.
But you get guys that come in,
I'm like Lance Palmer now even fight himself,
he's wanting to Pfl you got all these guys have been fighting 10 12 years before
they meet mark.
So it's kind of like they just tuning up.
Sorry thing when you've got a guy like me to has nothing.
The Gym I was at,
we literally like all that roof sport for a little bit.
But I got to college coaching job and had to leave.
So I met a group of guys do Mark Fiori at the time,
but he ended up leaving to go to overseas and it was probably six of us and we
had to find a guy who owned the warehouse.
Like all you can put mats in here and just in a corner.
You guys need to train.
We didn't have Jujitsu practice.
Whenever has striking practice,
no tie practice.
We really showed up ground and pound.
It would make gloves.
We Punch each other in the face for learning.
I get out sparring,
no bridge,
jazz and spawn.
I mean,
you've got injuries.
We don't want to hear it.
Just beat the shit out of each other until it's over.
There was,
it was the horrible one at a time.
No heat.
We had a little curious here about this big on the corner mat and we for we in
Illinois.
Oh Geez.
The mid Central Illinois.
It's freezing negative twin.
We in their fucking dudes brake and hit the hand,
hit the back,
freeze and break the hand.
We don't have any insurance.
US beating the shit out of each other,
but we got the opportunity for one of us,
it was three two oh five hours,
but I was the only one that they was gonna let to go show the ultimate fighter.
I had the least amount of fights with.
You're the only one I can actually work and make us look good on their get
a fighter.
You meet Mark Henry,
you want to win and,
and then you go from there.
You Go and move to New Jersey.
I went home,
I met Ali on the show.
You know,
Ali was there every day.
He even said like,
Bro,
you're in,
it's got like how you get arrested.
Enzo came on,
he said like,
you're wrestling this key.
That's when everybody let me know.
Mark,
first thing you say is your wrestling.
They made it known like wrestling is going to run this and uh,
and the valleys there,
I think he's like,
oh,
I'll work with you.
And the union had assignments,
a manager,
but I help you.
I help lead you in the right way.
What unique,
cause I didn't have anybody to direct me.
I knew nothing.
Been asking him the only thing I had,
but he was in Wisconsin,
you know,
I'm about,
I hear on my own and Holly,
I remember her saying like,
if you want to win,
it's showing to be the best you can,
brother,
you need to go to Jersey and mark and I'm and already texting me.
You're more than welcome to come out and train whenever you want.
By the time I had a girl who had a kid and my family and the kosher with my
dream job,
still my dream job and I love that.
You know,
I didn't want to leave that for anything.
What were you coaching your college wrestling?
Got By the junior college level.
And I remember,
uh,
that was the only made 220 bucks a week.
But I worked other jobs to make my dream a reality.
That's why I wanted to do and fight.
And um,
how do you like,
if you want to be the best,
you want to win to show the Best I've you got man,
you need to go to Jersey.
Like I know you got guys there,
but even my guys told me after the show you need to leave cause we can't do
anything for you.
But I didn't want to,
I was so grounded today.
I didn't want to leave that.
That's what I knew.
And uh,
well he say,
Bro,
you got to go.
But I can never live in Jersey is too fast paced.
I'm a country boy.
I like outdoors and this hunting and stuff like that.
Like you need to get the Jersey brother if you want to be the best,
if you don't want to be the best,
stay where you are.
I remember telling my mom,
like I said,
I need to go to Jersey.
I'm mom said when I was,
uh,
in high school,
my senior year,
you get the opportunity ever to leave.
I want you to go far away.
Did you think about going anywhere else?
Like go on Rufus sport permanently or,
and that was a thought?
Yeah.
Thought,
but he didn't have the rest have been,
but that was about it.
You know,
I'm a wrestling base and I fell in love with the way Frankie and I'm trying,
I love that.
I was looking for something like that mark for,
you already had that,
but when he left,
had nowhere else to go and I was thinking,
and my mom said,
if that's what the best is,
you need to go be the best.
You know?
My brother was like,
Yo,
let's go.